hello everybody my name is markiplier
and I'm once again joined by the likes
of wait wait hey guys hey you're awfully
cheerful and peppy this morning how are
you doing this more up I feel great
after last well then tell me about it
what do you feel so good in about we
went down into the mine oh yes you went
down all right and then when you I fed
you my meat and then you gobbled it up
did you like my meat Wade I guess last
night wasn't as good hahaha it's all
coming back to you now best you missed
oh yeah cuz you're building the roof
okay um you know don't run your life
okay Who am I now my Hershel we kind of
got messed up on the axes I don't know
who's who anymore I don't know love
don't know either how do I get out of
here
milk milk where wait what Lucas where oh
yeah okay
Oh yuck okay that noise if you look cuz
my noise bother you look seriously at
more they make that look uh yeah on dead
piece of me huh good with Chuck my
shotgun Oh yuck
oh look god there's so many of them why
are there so many of them oh-ho puke Oh
yuck
oh York oh yeah there literally is just
like an unlimited amount why are there
so many oh did we do something wrong
Wade I don't think so huh huh all right
I'm getting out there enough of this I
marry you I'm gonna get you oh I should
have reloaded before I got ya oh I'd
walk her in the house why look he's dead
alright I gotta go get some more of that
wood that is a lie
lot of dead bodies but how are they
getting in overdue they're not getting
in I just opened a place that I could
get to him man all the bodies are
disappearing boy yeah that sucks and
what the hell I killed too many of them
I'm just too prolific on my killing miss
miss you can't even handle you right now
can't even handle me right this moment
than it is to know the way that I'm
gonna put a lot of torches under here
now because I don't want enemies to
spawn or be able to run very fast here
really bad interests on to a cartoon
that shouldn't exist when I was late or
early 90s cartoons that were just
god-awful like they're adventurers and
running did I mention that they were all
animals and they got a human friend oh
yeah you're gonna have a photo oh ow dog
a heavy dog yeah oh yeah oh yeah I
killed goofy Oh yuck Oh yuck Oh yuck
yuck yuck that's the name of this
episode's gonna be oh you look how you
gonna spell a UHG UK or something UHG
okay what yeah I guess G watch you get
the guilt it's gotta be you look it's
aah - hy u w k ck okay look okay you get
it do you get what I'm saying
look are you picking up what I'm putting
down are you sliding in when I'm sliding
out iced are you slamming forward when
I'm slamming back are you digging it
what I am digging out what are you
jiggling I'm not digging I'm jiggling
well yeah yeah tickling I'm vaguely shut
up shut up it didn't happen I don't know
you didn't see anything
not a thing not a thing it was all just
in your mind it was all a dream it was
only dream that is that song or
something I don't
it was all a dream
so when I looked into your eyes who Anna
looked in what that is a song Wow
where'd you come from
yeah that's it can I say that
what McDonald's yeah you could say the
word it's not that bad I don't know man
you don't know man you don't know she's
getting crazy out wait wait wait
you think you know but you don't you
think I didn't expect that but I did
mask you Jim
what oh how are you doing how's the farm
coming
oh very good are you mom digging dirt in
dirt that's good good good I'm raising
the roof you know what I guess a about
you we're wait nobody questioned wait
have you seen anchorman 2 yet no I
haven't no you gotta see I'm not gonna
spoil for anyone but you gotta see
there's a funniest joke in there about
like ending sentences with questions
like anyone out there knows what I'm
talking about but I mean oh it is so
funny it was like I really wanna go see
it like immediately it is so funny okay
no ball isn't seen the first one I got
occur watch the first one why I know oh
because you made recently I'm gonna make
her watch it in basil basil oh I meant
to rewatch Austin Powers I haven't seen
it you got the reference well I was
pretty good yeah mmm who else is named
basil I mean honestly well there's
actually a Disney movie that I used to
watch called the Great Mouse Detective
and I loved that your street Oh and then
uh and um no that was the rescuers sorry
I wasn't mistaken but yeah a great mouse
protect what the rescuers - that's a
good old one yeah the rescuers the
rescuers down on his risotto
underappreciated Disney movie yeah yeah
but I had though like the whole VHS
collection man we're getting so
nostalgic up in here blood what do you
think of flubber
I like flubber I like flubber - a lot of
people didn't like flubber and I was
just like you are crazy
I love flub a zoo Oh
uh-oh the the pagemaster you remember
that that was one of my favorite dad
Macaulay Culkin I just figured that out
recently I didn't know there was
Macaulay Culkin really young back then I
know who's crazy anyway yeah this yes I
think we just dated ourselves but that's
okay I'm sure some of our audience is
older than us
right right rate comment subscribe if
you're older than us be sure I like how
they order I've owned dr. B your great
Apollo your daddy we're gonna get your
daddy grandpa you're the daddy grandpa
my baby baby but that's a whole nother
story
do we need clay for anything uh I don't
know what clays I feel like we do I
think you make bowls with clay and
that's how you make that's how you cook
the venison you need like oh could you
make the stew and you do this you with
your vanishing and you put the vanishing
anything we just you yeah whatever the
devil you're trying to say don't you
give me that stash you've been doing the
weirder voice was here I do not happen
to know with what you are talking then
your mouth oh yes very much so I do not
understand the pontiff vacations if you
are making through Oracle's focus in
focus uh orifice that is the word that I
was trying to find Oedipus Oedipus had a
bit of a complex if you know what I mean
yes he did describe his mom oh good
description the most apt and distinct
did sorry I had trouble we're getting
that word out yeah yeah sorry I had a
taste in the back of my throat yeah
was it a good taste it was not it was a
terrible taste that is too bad that is
two clicks short of a row two kliks
short of a bull's ass if you ask me two
bullets sort of a selling black ass if
you ask me click what click ass click
click ass like ass your ass a click of
ass that is that like what dolphins do
to communicate no no you remember like
cliques in high school in college yeah
but it's a clique of asses
oh my clique we're in high school in
college yeah there was ha ha ha ha ha
wait what cuz I called I called everyone
that was in cliques I just
I just called them all nevermind I can't
believe you said that way I really can't
believe you even thought the sensor that
there's nothing it's pretty horrible I
mean I planted oh it went away
wait what I what went away what happened
it won't stay in the dirt Wade what the
potatoes what do you mean they won't
stay in the dirt eh won't stay in the
dirt
what oh that one did nevermind false
alarm
hahaha I'm just so silly well look at me
özil II what I thought like at first I
looked down I thought the entire debt
collapse haha no not quite but these
potatoes are getting away from me it's
getting dark yeah and the potatoes went
in the dirt damn it we don't agree what
that means a pity I just went in the
dirt aren't they supposed to know no
they went underneath the dirt and I'm
loosing potatoes fast that's not good
no it's not I'll tell you what is good
potatoes no I was gonna say cracker bro
oh yeah it is
yeah you know uh Molly and I eat it five
guys today you did she never been to
five guys she went there with you and I
the one time oh wait what we went to
five guys um one day whenever we went to
your house for something near your place
I don't think that's true
ah it's getting dark we should guns we
spent like an hour with the certain
teller and then we went to table guys
what you were having a banking issue
what you don't remember this at all
no I don't know what you're talking
about we went to the league game stop
and five guys and no not ringing any
bells
yeah that's Todd it's almost dark we
gotta get the outro intro that's what
you bought all your computer's parts oh
yeah no I don't remember you away
what no I have no idea where you're
dying really I have no idea how do you
not remember I don't remember geez get
off my back best memories get off my
back
but get off my back house then ah
you ruined our window what window you
broke the other haha okay so we're
making progress our farm is almost
completed moments p.m. or what we didn't
seal up the bottom floor who cares I did
cuz I know what okay so thank you all so
much for watching crap out of me my good
progress right wait what progress
progress good good progress oh my god
mark come here what look at this lady's
body why am I looking at this lady's
body then over here Ron man look at it
what about it is it not look all freaky
to you know what are you talking about
it looks like a tent her butt is like
not like red no it does not look like
that even a little bit wait like this
huge way wait is going crazy you can't
even see what he's dying about I think
he's a lying liar
Oh anyway thank you all so much for
watching click the annotation for more
videos that I've done check out weights
channel in the description or click on
his lovely face bill you seven seven
seven bye
oh my god they want to get through that
wall real bad yeah I can't believe you
didn't see that weird conclusion oh
you've got some glitches that I do not I
know they're freaky they're freaky
freaky deaky almost leaky freaky deaky
we've actually almost successfully
completed this farm how how am i what
how I I don't understand what the word
how is asking me here how surprised or
how we almost completed it how do you do
that thing that you do now you do that
voodoo that you things so carefully
Hayden may prefer I couldn't make cereal
I could make us a metal door if that
would help us yeah I think I'd be good
alright then I shall I have no idea what
it was good would do but I think we need
it we have it now it yes L is that
potatoes what are you doing I was
freaking out for a minute why I don't
know you're very disturbing this just
came over me think the disturbing is
your ally Oh forgive us key they've
gotten through ah
Cripe look York job look I can't even
here look where do we want our door not
there not there I'm thinking here oh I
was about to fill that in okay I've got
a door what does this look like just
look like a door it's like a little mini
refrigerator wall panel I'm gonna put it
right where I think the door you scared
me right there okay
you dig one or the other and oh no no no
no no no no we're in trouble
burn trouble Oh trouble hello we're
Javal reloading wait why'd you do that
wait why'd you do that
look uh hook died oh yeah I diaper rash
diaper rest I can't place the door
because their bodies are in the way
oh wait there we go no hang out no I
can't is bodies literally who for a
minute move for a minute good idea
there you know I can't because the
bodies are in the way literally even out
there yeah and yeah Ace Ventura back
iris I got it reloading we seem to be in
a bit of a spot here Wade a little bit
of a tish-tosh
little cup of tea spot I guess ah
I literally cannot place it why why
can't we kill these [ __ ] or get rid
of him at least bogey ah wait no no
there's a gap there's a gap got it get
in here
woo swoosh alright we do jump in
celebration ray-ray
hey for us are you gonna you celebratory
meat gobbling I I was I know him Dunham
rugs mm-hmm you need drugs what happened
to you you little baby did you get a
little bit of an owie in your 40 rounds
a little bit before I take my drugs
excuse me I like to let the zombies
sleep yeah I'm not your piece of oh
you're talking about the zombies yeah
can they break down that door probably
eventually will they be able to do it in
one night probably nah I see some Oh
why'd you do that okay I see what you
did
gosh you're so brave I know I can't
believe it
usually no sexy oh I'm gonna back you
into that corner mr. kitty that corner
that corner
do ya corner uh-huh you get in that
corner huh Doris though it's gotta be
good I'm gonna get a baby baby baby this
time baby that ready waiting baby for
another baby baby baby
haha you like that baby you like that
baby baby baby motorboat it your belly
button hahahaha was it good for you a
brewski
oh I'm reloading reloading kill kill
kill kill kill
thank you you walked right in front of
me when you said kill kill kill Wade you
know you want to
can we never repair this thing uh
actually I think you can if you make
like a wrench somebody said oh how to
make a wrench I don't see a wrench in my
thing I'm gonna make some forging metal
just in case that's needed rip other
forged metal or metal pipes or something
I don't know okay I've got forging metal
I see short metal pipe I'm just gonna
make some random crap yeah that's good
experiment see what that makes you might
have to like find a wrench okay so an
iron ingot will turn into forging metal
which is like a plank of wood and that
turns into pipe okay okay so that a
red-alert tool got it okay I'm assuming
a repair tool is this a bunch of pipe
which it is which makes a wrench here I
dropped one for you yes don't get too
excited there bubby mmm so good
Steve hmm funk me bang funk you're
fixing it you're dead right click the
repair
left click ah you repaired her face can
you repair can you repair anything with
this hand I don't know you can look at
this [ __ ] lettuce oh yeah it's so weird
and cool they don't cost a lot it's like
one iron can make an entire repair tool
with some extra to spare oh it's so nice
oh thank you you shot me I think like a
people what it's knocking at the door
did you really think there was someone
out there to let in I kinda [ __ ] are
you okay I'm gonna make more stuff Rhian
firon reinforced clubs spiked club
wooden club coal torch ooh that sounds
fancy
I'm gonna make one of those just to see
what it is a coal torch yeah it's a
torch a torch but with coal it's
probably a brighter torch I would
imagine
he remotes Oh that'd be good for a
garden maybe maybe here does this seem
any brighter to you well here place one
put it down
that's nothing different it on a flame
on top no they all have flames on top
you dick wait a mine mine doesn't it's
just glowing orange no they all have
flames you bastard well this is no
better it when I picked it up it turned
into a normal porch what the hell this
is stupid
all right whatever there's more stuff
here this is only alpha there's also a
scrap metal door gardening ho which I'm
assuming that we'll need ya ladder
medley that what is metal trussing hey
where's the dirt at the head of potato
oh no but I'm gonna make a metal
trusting it's like potatoes to plant I
do you wanted disappeared I don't know
why what some poo disappeared did you
know dirt here yeah I did but I digged
it up I dug it up rather it's the proper
English Kings it why'd you do that
because it was IDing the sprouts make a
hoe and you get on with your business
can you make it a builder's roof I'm Oh
bill doesn't Laurie so we're not lonely
how are you gonna don't answer I'm gonna
build a lorry cuz I'm gonna build it
goods involve your left hand ha ha ha no
it involves both hands Oh
what that is big one big sensor bleep so
it was just like the most horrible thing
you're gonna possibly said got you [ __ ]
anything at all I've got you I just AM
looking with the most horrified face I'm
just like oh my god oh I have you now